I used to play a game with my
grandmother when she wasn't looking our
grandma's finger I have slight foot
fetish
you have a slight slight slight you once
had your down below peers uh-huh and
down below you mean like your calf the
longest I think the long relationship is
alive I've seen her I think I was once
arrested for assault and battery
is like that one for mine I need to play
a game with my grandmother when she
wasn't looking our grandma's finger one
year I went to college I was going to
get married and it was the best
oh no the last one there with college I
never went to college the game when my
grandmother was tall hey hey no no
because what happens but oh yeah you try
it you do it and you no matter who you
do it - they can't help they say hey so
we caught it was called it was called
the hey-hey game I once got a teacher
fired for kicking him in the head you
kicked him in the head and you got him
fired on that he got fired okay all
right I lost my virginity when I was 12
I got hit by a train I was 13
I say you lost your virginity was going
really wrong you couldn't get away from
the guy and you rank my history I
wouldn't I think the virginity is alive
[Applause]
[Laughter]
the first time I got really drunk I
threw up into a KFC bucket that's braces
[Music]
when I was younger I ran into a barbed
wire fence on a quad bike I had to get
six stitches
I thought the moon I genuinely thought
the movies made out of cheese until I
was grateful can't see bucket barbed
wire fence so you say why you say - I've
got my six sisters I think if one of us
had to win I think I want no definitely
the most right I got the most right and
nobody picked mine okay I think I won
you made the biggest
[Music]
[Music]